i saw a comment recently that was
someone
complaining that opengl is no longer
supported and they were wondering what
to do with their opengl knowledge and
was all their time wasted
and so on and so forth
i want to answer the question that
they posed
that was basically is it
always time absolutely not if you're
into graphics
it is fine all these concepts you can
learn on some place like learn opengl
they apply to all rendering
there might be little differences if
you're going to go to directx
or vulcan
but in general you're gonna see these
same terms
and they're gonna have different names
sure like instead of gl frag cord you'll
have whatever vulcan or directx this
version of that but these concepts
remain so
it is absolutely worth it to learn
opengl
and it's a great place to start if
you're
too intimidated by the others
it doesn't hurt
but of course
you
you should be encouraged to branch out
when you feel comfortable
there's no reason to stick with just one
of them if you want to support
specialized hardware
you might stick with one but if you want
to do a broader level of support
it's going to be better to learn these
concepts and apply them as needed to the
render of your setup of your choice
for what you're doing
so i think it makes a lot of sense to uh
support a wide variety of platforms if
you're making a game
because it is going to limit your
audience
quite a bit if you only release in one
place
there are a lot of examples of this um
yeah i'm sure you guys can find them if
you want them leave a comment if you
think of one but that's it for this
episode of
game engine quick tech talks or whatever
the heck i'm naming this all right see
you guys in the next one
you